hello all of you came is out there my
name is prestige and this is my new
gaming channel i'll be posting stuff
like call of duty and mine cut probably
called you for the first start and I got
a little later and that's about me I
hope you guys are built will be enjoying
this I will try and keep it up
interesting on people it's not a zombies
send a lot of a lot of people do
multiplayer images amies I know there's
a multiplayer but it's kind of hard to
get like an epic zombies clip so hope
you guys understand a little bit about
the gambling mean mv7 silence or red dot
number and out later site and using dual
c4 with a scavenger running these hot
dogs and a swarm this is a swarm
gameplay it's pretty pretty nice I kind
of dominate them in the first half i
dominate the middle and in the second
half i calling the killstreaks and my
team is triple caps and we wreck so
hopefully your guys going to enjoy this
playing with a few teammates and yeah
about that's all pretty much it about
the gameplay you kind of just tip any
tips for to get a swarm just dominate
the middle you're you're not gonna get
unless you dominate aside so don't make
the middle I take it I get it one flag
it be and then when they ever go to be
just wrecking like that so yeah I hope
subscribe make sure you subscribe I
would really appreciate that make sure
you leave this video a like and that's
pretty much it I'll be seeing you guys
later i'll be posting more so like this
so subscribe more and enjoy the gameplay
is out
Oh
security
lightning strike
check your timeline
good job grunts get ready for the next
round
domination capture the objectives
securing Charlie canine unit awaiting
orders we've taken control friendly
canine unit in your AO
securing B
Bravo secure
all flag security hold your positions
friendly hunter killer drone deployed
securing be care package inbound call
flag secured maintain current posture
objective almost
you